for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
if you've got a particle traveling
through space then its location or
position is definite at any instant in
time alright if you throw a ball it
starts at a certain point and as it's
going through through the air and then
eventually when it's coming down you can
at any point any time it's location is
definite it's that's right it could be
right here at one in stand-in right here
here along it has a certain path that it
follows okay waves aren't like that they
kind of spread out through space you
can't really define an exact location of
a wave alright and they also diffract
now there's an issue because electrons
have properties of both right they have
wave particle duality so what does that
mean well that's where the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle comes into play
Heisenberg uncertainty principle states
that it is not possible to know both an
electrons position or location and its
momentum at the same time right momentum
is equal to mass times speed right or
mass times velocity but in this case
we're going to think about speed so
another way to actually say this is that
it is not possible to know both an
electrons position and speed at the same
time so the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle can be expressed
mathematically like this Delta x times M
Delta u is greater than or equal to H
over 4 pi where Delta X is the
uncertainty in position the Delta is the
uncertainty the X is the position so X
is the particles position in meters
Delta X is the uncertainty in position
in meters m is the particles mass in
kilograms Delta U is the uncertainty
because we have that Delta it's against
certainty in the particle speed
particle speed is you that's in meters
per second H is just Planck's constant
which we've seen before and for pi is
just the number of contents literally
just four times pi has no units okay so
there are two variables here really
there are there's the particles position
and the particle speed notice that both
are not actually in this equation new or
in this inequality rather it's the
uncertainty in position and the
uncertainty of in the particle speed
that are here not the actual position
the actual speed okay what's the idea
here what's the key the key is that be
more accurately we know one variable the
less accurately we know the other
variable if we know a value more
accurately there's a smaller delta value
which means less uncertainty we're less
uncertain if we know it more accurately
right and if the value is larger if your
larger delta value that means we have
more uncertainty so the idea here is
that if we know one one of these values
one of these variables more accurately
will know the other less accurately
because if we have a smaller delta value
in one will have a larger delta value in
the other it'll be less uncertain more
uncertain about the others so let's kind
of turn this into an actual math problem
what's the use in a math problem so
let's think about example one which is
on the atomic scale okay so the problem
says an electron moving around the
nucleus of a particular atom at a speed
of four times ten to the six meters per
second plus or minus one percent all
right so that means this speed within
one percent find the uncertainty in the
electrons position okay so the first
thing we do is we write out the actual
equation like it is here right
delta x times m delta u is greater than
or equal to H over 4 pi we're going to
do is we're going to solve before
they're asking for they're asking for
the uncertainty in the electrons
position so that's going to be Delta X
so we'll solve it for delta x by
dividing both sides by M Delta u so
we'll have this Delta X is greater than
or equal to H over 4 pi m delta u so in
order to find the uncertainty in the
electrons position we must have h 4 pi m
and Delta V 0 so we have h h is just
Planck's constant which is right there
ok 4 pi is just 4 pi we got that M is
the mass of the particle so they're
asking specifically about an electron
and the mass of electron is 9.11 times
10 to the negative 31st kilograms so we
got that and we need Delta you what did
I give us result to you they don't
actually give us del to you they give us
the speed the speed is you this is you
this is not Delta you ok and they tell
us that it's within one percent of this
so what we're going to do to find Delta
U is take this percentage and of course
it's going to be 0 point 0 1 and
multiply that by the speed you just four
times ten to the six meters per second
and when we multiply them that will give
us the actual Delta u so be four times
ten to the fourth meters per second that
is our Delta u ok so now this is what we
got here alright so that's no longer a
question mark but so we've got all those
those values we just plug it in so Delta
X is equal or greater than or equal to H
over 4 pi m delta u so we'll plug in H
on the top at six points to 6 times 10
and 8 of 34 now I'm not going to write
Jules times seconds because the jewel is
one kilogram times meters squared per
second squared and that isn't me x
seconds so
one of these seconds will cancel here
and we'll get kilograms times meters
squared per second so those are the
units that I actually put here for for
the setup Jules times second so I can
actually see the units canceling i will
put 4 pi down here and i'll put the mass
of the electron here 9.11 x times and I
or 31 kilograms and Delta u in meters
per second is what we just found there
four times ten to the fourth meters per
second so now these units going to
cancel the kilograms cancel here the one
of these meters cancel these per seconds
cancel and then all that i'm left with
is meters and the value that I get is
1.45 times 10 to the negative nine
meters okay so that's like a billionth
of a meter right which is really tiny so
the question is this is a tiny amount of
uncertainty right or is this tiny
medicine certainty and if you think
about it just just you know at face
value yeah that's a really really tiny
distance but this is not a tiny amount
of uncertainty when we think about what
this really is referring to we're
talking about electrons flowing in an
atom so this is actually not a tiny
amount of uncertainty why because
compare it to the size of an atom which
we've mentioned it the diameters are on
the order of 10 to the negative 10
meters this value this Delta X that we
found here is 10 to the negative 9
meters which is actually 10 times bigger
than the diameter of an atom suppose
that means the uncertainty in the
position of this electron is larger than
the size of the atom that it's in it's
10 times bigger than the the atoms
diameter so what does that mean that
means I mean in short it means that we
really don't know where this electron is
right specifically it means we can't
really accurately know where this
electron moving at this particular speed
actually is because it's bigger than its
it's the uncertainty is bigger than the
actual diameter
we're we're thinking about it being
right so we really have no clue where in
that ad on this electronics and bear in
mind this is because we know the speed
right let's think about something on a
macroscopic scale how it compares okay
macroscopic scale so problem here is a
baseball 145 grams is thrown at
ninety-nine point nine miles per hour
within one percent find the uncertainty
of the baseball's position so it's the
same idea we're going to use the same
the same equation here we're going to
solve it for Delta X because they're
asking for they're asking for the
uncertainty in position that is Delta X
so that's what we saw for so it's
basically the same as before it's the
same exact situation in terms of what
they're asking us to solve for the
difference here is that we have
different units we are given the
baseball's mass in grams we have to
convert that to kilograms and we're
given the massive miles per hour which
we have to convert meters per second so
miles per hour let's convert that let's
start by converting the hour so we got
one hour on top so the unit's cancel
that's 60 minutes and so that that'll
give us miles per minute if I cancel the
hours there so now we have a unit in
miles per minute still not what we want
we've got to get rid of these minutes
one minute on top to cancel the minutes
60 seconds on the bottom so the minutes
will cancel here and now we have miles
per second so the per second part is
good we have to convert these miles two
meters and we'll put one mile on the
bottom in 1609 meters on top that's an
approximation but it's got four sig figs
so we're going to roll with it so the
miles cancel and then we're left with
meters per second so if you multiply
this all the way through what you should
get is 44 point 25 meters per second now
that's the actual you that's the speed
of the baseball so we have to find the
uncertainty in the speed so we're going
to take the point zero one right because
the one percent say point 0 1 and
multiply it by this in
meters per second speed 44.2 5 meters
per second that's going to be 0 point 4
4 to 5 meters per second and of course
we already have h 4 pi and the mass
which is given here and now that we
found that delta T we can plug it all in
so H same as before six point six to six
times ten to the negative thirty four
kilograms times meters squared per
second for pie same as before the mass
here 145 grams at the point 1 45
kilograms because has to be in kilograms
to cancel and the speed or this could be
the uncertainty in speed point 4 4 to 5
meters per second it was there so again
we're gonna go through and cancel these
units kilograms cancel one of these
meters cancel the per seconds cancel and
we're left with just metres the answer
that we get here is at the Delta X is
greater than or equal to 8.2 2 times 10
to the negative 34 meters now this is
much smaller right than what we found
before so is this a tiny amount of
uncertainty in this case absolutely yes
let's compare it to the size of the
baseball a baseball is the diameter is
approximately point zero seven three
meters so this 8.22 times 10 to negative
34 meters is way smaller than zero point
zero seven three meters in fact it's
it's over 30 magnitudes over 30 orders
of magnitude smaller so that would look
like this basically one with over this
is with 30 zeros i think i put here so
it's over that many times smaller than
the baseballs diameter so that's a super
super super small amount of uncertainty
what does that mean we're that means
we're really really really not uncertain
about where this baseball actually is so
it means specifically that we can very
accurately know where this baseball is
when it's moving at the speed that's
mentioned here right so
what's the point of this right why did I
give you one of the atomic scale into
macroscopic scale the point is that on
on a macroscopic scale like this problem
uncertainty is essentially negligible
right this value is so small compared to
the size of the baseball that we could
take it to pretty much equal zero right
and so because of that on a macroscopic
scale we can very accurately know both
position and speed of a particle on the
atomic scale however uncertainty is not
negligible and instead the more
accurately we know position the less
accurately we know speed right and also
the opposite is true or the vice versa
or likewise what happens the more
accurately we know speed the less
accurately we know position that's why i
put respectively here okay so so what
right why care what does this even mean
why is this important at all right well
what this means is that we cannot say
that electrons flow around the nucleus
in a fixed path because we can't
actually know its position right so
that's that's the idea behind the boards
boards orbits right his model mentioned
that electrons to float around the
nucleus in a very fixed path and that's
not the case that can't be the case
because we can't exactly know the
position and speed of of an electron at
the same time so instead we can only
comment on the likelihood or the
probability that an electron will be in
a certain region and that's one of the
that's part of like the basis for the
quantum mechanical model or want some
Theory so I hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying